من حرب اهليه محتمله مصطلح جديد فرض نفسه
على الخطاب الاسرائيلي في ظل ازدياد
الانقسامات في المجتمع بنحو غير مسبوق
وتصاعد الامور نحو الاسوا فيما يتعلق
بالازمه القضائيه حيث يتوافد مئات
المتظاهرين للشوارع يوميا دون توقف لمده
تزيد عن عشره اسابيع على التوالي لم يعتقد
ان حرب الاخوه حرفيا بين الافراد هي حدود
لن نصل اليها لا توجد لديه فكره عما يحدث
وعلى خلفيه اقاله قائد شرطه تل ابيب من
قبل المفوض العام للشرطه شفتاي بالحاح من
وزير الامن القومي بنج فير بسبب التساهل
بالتعامل مع الاحتجاجات انتقادات وغضب
شديد بين المتظاهرين وكبار الضباط
الحاليين مؤكدين ان شبتاي خاضع للضغوطات
السياسيه وطالبه بالاستقاله وكان قد اعترف
شفتاي انه اخطا في الموافقه على القرار
ولن يستسلم للضغوط السياسيه وتم تجميد
القرار لاحقا
لن ننساهم هم يحاولون جلب الفاشيه لبلادنا
لن نتنازل سنحارب حتى اخر